- We're very happy to be here.
We're here, we're doing it!
- Yay!
- Hi, guys, I'm here with Lisa Schwartz.
And we just recorded a full
episode of "Not Too Deep,"
which was very educational.
- Yeah, but not too deep!
- Exactly.
No, you have to listen to
it to really understand it.
So make sure you go over
to iTunes or SoundCloud
and listen to that episode.
But right now, we're gonna play--
- Oh boy.
- We're gonna play a familiar game,
"Cards Against Humanity,"
which you may or may not know about.
But we're gonna put the
YouTuber twist on it.
which is a thing I saw.
Shane and Colleen did a
video like this recently,
and I thought it would be really fun,
where I asked you guys on Facebook
to give me topics,
YouTuber-centric topics,
that Lisa and I can pull cards from
and try and figure out
what is the most appropriate
response to those topics.
- And then you can title this,
"The YouTuber Cards Against Humanity,"
which will get more clicks.
So internet!
Clickbait!
- Do YouTube.
That's your TED talk, it's
just called "Clickbait."
(dramatic classical music)
And our first topic is
YouTuber book titles.
- Oh, so good!
- So we're each gonna pull
three cards without looking.
- I'm looking.
- And now from these three cards,
we get to choose the one that
we think is the best answer.
Oh no.
(exaggerated struggling)
All "New York Times"
bestsellers right here.
Okay, this one is my entry.
- It's between two and I feel
like I'm making the wrong
choice, but I'm over it.
- Okay, here you go.
- Okay.
The first one on the list is
"Farting and Walking Away."
A very serious final pick.
- That's like what happens
when I post a YouTube video,
it's basically a digital fart
and then I walk away from it.
- That's incredible.
- You guys tell me whose book this is.
It's entitled, "Penis Envy."
- Yes.
(laughing)
- What do you guys think?
- [Voiceover] Are we voting collectively?
- It's up to you guys.
- [Voiceover] "Penis Envy."
- "Penis Envy."
What YouTubers do on a Friday night.
- Are we talking about
most YouTubers or me?
(laughing)
- Okay, whoops.
Oh, oh, oh, well, yep.
Okay.
Yes, yes.
- Oh, this is sad.
- Mine got real meta.
German dungeon porn.
So if you ever wonder what
(mumbles) does on a Friday night.
(laughing)
- Google it.
And this says, "Cards Against Humanity."
Whoa!
- Too real?
Too real, I'm sorry.
- Too real.
- Okay, I'll let you guys decide.
- [Voiceover] Dungeon porn.
(laughing)
- They're all like, that's what we do.
- Everyone just shamefully.
Okay.
The next topic is "Troye
Sivan's new song is called..."
- Oh, this is so mean.
(laughing)
- These aren't the best, I
wish I had different options.
- I wanna switch options with you
and see which one of these
you would have picked.
- Do you wanna do that?
- Yeah, because you know which
one you would have picked.
- Yep, okay we're switching.
Oh, yeah.
Oh!
These are real mean!
- There's no way of winning!
- Can I pick two?
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- Okay, it'll be the title
that the radio gives the song,
and then the real title of the song.
The radio title of the song is "Go-Gurt."
The actual real title of the song is
"Rush Limbaugh's Soft Shitty Body."
(laughing)
- I chose "David Bowie Flying on a Tiger
"Made of Lightning."
This is art!
- Oh how do you choose?
- We're all winners, he's the winner here!
- Truly, the audience, you win.
Let Troye know which title you
want his newest song to be.
And spam him with your Twitter
because that's the only
way change happens.
This is, "The newest YouTube
trend is the Blank Challenge."
- Oh, this is good.
- Why is this not a thing for
choosing YouTube challenges?
Just blindly choosing.
- Maybe it is.
- [Voiceover] It'll probably become one.
- Can I re-up my cards?
(laughing)
- Yes, yes you can.
Because YouTube challenges
are very important.
You gotta take this seriously.
- Those are no good.
- This could go viral.
- Oh, yes.
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Okay, I'm gonna use all three.
The new YouTube challenge is a variation
of "(censored), Marry, Kill"
called "Foreskin, Nazis, Dead Babies."
(laughing)
You just have to decide who's who.
I didn't say it's gonna be a
successful YouTube challenge.
- No, it's a legit challenge.
This feels like a feasible one.
It's the "Invisible Hand" challenge.
Do you know what I mean?
We gotta work on this one.
- All you need is a green
screen and a green glove--
- And then the body's the limit.
- Lisa, thank you so
much for participating.
- The best of the best.
- This was more or less just a
brainstorming session for us.
- We'll get back to you on this.
Check in in a couple weeks.
- And make sure that you go
listen to the full podcast
on iTunes or SoundCloud, "Not Too Deep,"
with Grace Helbig and Lisa Schwartz.
And go check out Lisa's channel
because we shot a video over there
that will change your life in a way.
I don't know.
This domestic goddess right here.
You look adorable.
- Yeah.
(laughing)